yeah so here's the story travis kelsey
nfl star travis kelsey splits from his
girlfriend after making her pay for half
of everything
let me read the story nfl star travis
kelsey has reportedly split from his
long-term model girlfriend very
attractive yeah manchester united kaya
kayla nicole after apparently making her
pay for half of everything the breakup
has nothing to do with cheating
supposedly in fact it has to is said to
be over the 14 million dollar a year
kansas city chief star making nicole pay
for half of everything the couple would
split dinners
trips and other things kelsey's
reasoning is believed to be a test of
her true intentions going 50 50 was a
way for nicole to prove she wasn't just
in it for the monet
and she actually
liked him all right let me just weigh in
on this real quick if you could
take this girl's name uh kelly
and uh her name is kayla nicole
k-a-y-l-a
nicole that's a bad [ __ ] dude that's a
bad [ __ ] pull up some pictures and then
click net worth
you're gonna okay so there it shows some
images
we get it she's hot but go to her
network
let's just see if we can get that number
then you can go to an image of her
net worth okay who knows if this is
right get out of images go to all okay
nicole's net worth go ahead right there
two million dollars
you see that two million dollars
so she's got some bread actually hold on
scroll down it says
700k yeah okay so she makes some money
okay i gotta tell you
i understand what travis kelsey is doing
prove it to me baby like prove you're in
this
but you make 14 million dollars a year
bro
you don't have to split dinners i always
say this there's no there nothing will
get a hose
sorry
oh he didn't i meant to save pantyhose
nothing get a pantyhose dried up then
asking her to split a dinner and split a
check not a good look a lady i meant
that okay don't cut that i didn't mean
hoes like that meant pantyhose not a
good look for a multi-millionaire to be
splitting things like that do i
understand his perspective do i
understand that the woman needs to earn
it and earn the trust and prove that
she's not in it for the money by the way
if they ever did end up together there's
something called a prenup travis you
should probably look into that
so it do i understand the theory of what
he's doing but in practice i do not
think this is a good look if you're
making that much money be a freaking
gentleman pay for most of the stuff
maybe sometimes she can pay for stuff
but be the freaking man here i don't
think it's a good look do you agree or
disagree um i it depends on who you are
if you're travis kelsey future hall of
fame tight end for the kansas city
chiefs i think it's a great look and the
reason and here's the thing kayla nicole
might think oh to the average rank and
file man caleb kayla nicole would never
give a guy like me a shot so if she ever
did and i said hey can you pay for half
she's up out of there but trap but i'm
not travis kelsey you understand what i
mean women make exceptions for
exceptional men kayla nicolas probably
never bought a drink in her life until
she met travis kelsey on the flip side
of that this is where the strong and
independent woman comes back to bite
them in their collective ass because if
you want to be strong and independent
that's all well and good but then you
can't expect men like
like jason jason kelsey plays for our
hometown eagles so and they're brothers
but you can't expect you if if you're if
you're going to be this boss babe and
this and that in the third that's great
and i think that that's good especially
if something happens you want
devin has the skill set to if something
happens to me she can make money for
herself don't worry about me take care
of yourself but but this is when women
try to flex and be these boss babes a
guy like travis kazi's like okay you're
a boss babe you're making 700 large a
year cool we're going to split this 50
50. so being a boss babe and being
strong and independent is great but
there is a cost for everything kayla
nicole wanted to be the boss babe but
also still want to be taken care of
here's something else travis kelsey
would have would probably have paid for
things if he took her seriously i don't
care how long he's been with her if he
really took her seriously then he would
have been took her off the mark and said
you know what i got everything from now
on
this is why i took her off the market
uh our first our first quote-unquote
date was a trip to hawaii cost eight
thousand dollars she paid every penny of
it that's when i knew she was serious
hold on she paid for your guys first
trip yep i went to hawaii spent a week
together it's it's the best vacation
ever why did you feel the need to pay
for your man for this and then did you
feel like oh my god it was her
suggestion she said she texted me
she she texted me she said hey i'm going
to hawaii would you like to go i said if
you're paying i'm playing two hours
later she's like our flight leaves this
that in the third women if women truly
love you and care about you they'll
spend money on you i mean you gotta pay
for double occupancy anyway right there
you go but that i do agree with i have
planned trips if i plan the trip then i
do expect to pay for the trip and i
really planned trips with a significant
other and i paid for it but i planned it
was my
idea
something i wanted to do i want you to
do it with me so yeah i got it but i
believe when we got there he paid me
well hold on ladies
i gotta get your opinion on this
when should a man pay for everything
most of everything and when should women
pay so for example dinners i don't think
i've ever had a lady pay for dinner i i
like it just it just wouldn't happen wow
now if she went to the store and brought
groceries home i'm like oh that's so
sweet of you thank you amazing but if
we're going out for dinner i'm paying
okay even when i was broke as [ __ ] okay
now i've got some money things are good
i will pay right but when is it
acceptable for women to like if you're
gentlemen if you're gonna take a lady on
a first date and you try to split the
bill
you're not getting any okay buddy so
when is it acceptable for a woman to pay
versus amanda pay well i mean it's
whatever he chooses is acceptable and
whatever she chooses is acceptable at
the end of the day like i said earlier
when this podcast first started i if i
ask you out
this man if i'm asking you to hey let me
take you to dinner then that's on me i
want to take you to dinner if you're
asking me then i feel like
if i'd be like babe i want to go to um
ruth chris
hey
are you taking me there's a difference
because if i ask you hey you taking me
to roof chris i really want to go there
then i expect you to pay for it if i say
hey babe um
come on let me take you out we're going
to go to the roof's crest and have
dinner well and that's what i mean i
think it depends where you are in a
relationship if devon tonight were to
say hey let's go to roots chris i'm not
going to make her pay i'm going to pay
and the reason why i pay is because she
has earned my commitment um this is why
i always tell men never ever ever take a
woman out on a first date for dinner
these days back in the day that was
great that was the gentleman i'm gonna
get all my free meals well i heard
listen all you hustling girls out there
city girls get yours but when but if you
listen to guys like me this goes back to
earning the trust okay you're attractive
enough and i ask you out i'll pay for
drinks i'll pay for coffee
but i'm not about to pay for dinner for
a woman i don't know because i might not
like her if i take her out for coffee or
drinks and if i don't like you i'm damn
sure not gonna feed you i'll smash you
but i'm not gonna feed you if i don't
like you oh if when a woman earns a
man's trust and they want to go out at
that point the man definitely has to pay
because you're the man and you should
pay whereas in this situation this is a
very this is a very um this is a a
outlier situation you got a guy and he's
making 16.7 million dollars 14 million a
year well uh okay well his contract he's
making a ton of money he's making a ton
of money right you got this is this is
an exception to the rules she's hot
she's rich he's hot he's rich the rule
the the money ain't the same though
not even close the money the money is
different so the rules are different
right so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire sauce cast
click right here
you